ja da sind wir gleich da kann ich ja
gleich anschließend dass er sich noch
fragen wollte ich bin ein verwunderter
zeitungsleser nicht gestern man sieht
nicht als gestern geboren und auch nicht
mit dem kleinen finger gemacht deswegen
stelle ich immer noch meine frage hin
der frage ganz naiv könnte es nicht sein
dass so viel impfstoff gekauft wurde
dass man vielleicht eines tages
rechtfertigen muss wie viel mittel
aufgewandt wurden und wer da verdient
hat und dass man deswegen das auf teufel
komm raus
kämpfen muss und vielleicht fließende
auf provisionen die irgendwann mal
ich habe hier eine frage nicht eher
bleibt was sind das problem sie denn das
ist so ganz klarer ich wollte das nur
sagen diese frage treibt mich halt um
wie viele andere menschen in unserem
lande
da ich mich treibt um ich bin wirklich
sehr bewusst über ein umstand das hat
etwas mit gerechtigkeit mit
steuergerechtigkeit zu tun wir haben in
der bundesrepublik deutschland ich war
nämlich eine kfz steuer damit man weiß
was das ist die wurde in deutschland
eingeführt 1899 im übrigen 13 jahre
nachdem zum ersten mal ein tuk tuk
gerollt ist ja das wurde die ist aber
als luxussteuer apostrophiert 899 im
regierungsbezirk hessen-darmstadt dass
man nur verständnis diese steuer werden
in der bundesrepublik erhoben und ist
nun zwölfter stelle sein name vermögens
der dem steueraufkommen ein zwölfter
stelle sind im jahr etwa 915 milliarden
euro 60 millionen fahrzeuge sind in der
bundesrepublik deutschland der alter kfz
haftpflicht ich 60 millionen und es soll
ist es keine zweckgebundene
steuervergehen im bundeshaushalt auf
aber ursprünglich war mal die idee dass
sie eigentlich
keine leute da strahlt ihr mir all der
straßen und dem autofahren der
instandhaltung von straßen und ähnlichen
lass mich ausreden ja ja weil sie machen
die spitzen schon immer das also ist da
ist ich halte den supermärkten keine
veruntreuung veruntreuung von
steuergeldern die autofahrer finanzieren
das zubauen von stahl die bilder
innenstadtviertel straße gleicht heute
dem munde von chicago nur das lebendiger
werden sie wir versinken unsere
innenstädte in grabesstille wir machen
busspuren die radfahrer farben durch die
gegend ramallah bum bum dann sollen sie
verdammt noch mal auch mit ein stück
verantwortung übernehmen denn wir räumen
ihn ja ich fahre öffentlichen teil sie
denken nicht vorstellen nein ich fahre
pnv tut ob s-bahn u-bahn und so japan
hätten menschen hier sind und bin also
in einer situation dass ich mich frage
wieso müssen meine ganzen reichen
freunde die haben nur so träume zahlen
viel steuern wieso müssen die bezahlen
das die wirklich übel haften radfahrer
weil sie sich ideologisch als moralisch
besser fühlen durch die gegend inge das
zweites ich versuche eine
versicherungspflicht zu hart war die
radfahrer verursachen bei
personenschaden umfeld
63.500 im jahr jeder zweite unfall mit
personenschaden an dem ein radfahrer
verteilt verteidigt ist wurde durch den
radfahrer verursacht
statistische bundesamt wiesbaden
innenministerium bonn nachprüfbar keine
frage rufen sie an die könnten die
zahlen alle vorlegen doch jetzt kommen
wir allein nein ich möchte eine
versicherungspflicht haben denn die
fußgänger das sind es 75 prozent der
fahrradfahrer schuld sind haben keine
möglichkeit den täter zu verfolgen ich
habe in meinem bekanntenkreis leute die
kniescheibe gebrochen er zahlt er ist
eigentlich die fahren davon und sagen
kimpel hier also machen die stinkefinger
verstehen sie und deswegen ist das
ungerecht dass leute die ketscher zahlen
und die straßen umgebaut werden zu toten
werden soll so haben verwahrten wenn du
das sage also erstmals
versicherungspflicht das wäre nur eine
fahrradfahrer schützende sache denn der
fahrradfahrer haftet natürlich heute
schon werden wir ja aber das lösen sie
nicht durch das problem der
versicherungspflicht also erstens muss
man sagen der fahrradfahrer
kennzeichnungspflicht
jetzt sind die sicherungspflicht nur das
verstehen und zum anlagen ist gut zu
seinem thema steuern es ist hoffentlich
so dass wir ja beide kwapich steuer
liberale politiker sind die erstmal
stehen ja das ist eine steuer und das
ist das was mich an dem konzept ein
bisschen stört eigentlich an steuern die
finanzierungsfunktion für den staat und
mir geht offen gesprochen auf den senkel
dass wir ohnehin versuchen über steuern
permanent verhaltenssteuerung
herbeizuführen so machen sehr sauer ja
finde ich aber auch nicht gesagt hätte
und deswegen seiner grundstruktur dass
man immer jetzt fragen sollte ob man das
noch verschlimmbessert wenn man sagt man
will jetzt einradfahren besteuern wollen
sie damit eine lenkungswirkung im
prinzip der irgendeiner tätigkeit
wirkung nein ich finde das ist macht
sozusagen das system noch schiefer indem
sie sagen jetzt sozusagen wird eine
steuerungerechtigkeit durch die nächste
aggregat das ist so wie ich halte das
für einen hype und ich würde halt sagen
sie lösen die probleme jetzt nicht indem
wir versuchen das menschliche verhalten
durch immer mehr steuersituation
aufzublähen sondern am ende müssen wir
schon schauen und da sind wir uns glaube
ich ein wiedersehen heißt du sagen ja
wir hören die leistungsverweigerer ich
würde sagen wir müssen schon schauen
dass wir und es klang ja auch an in
ihren argumenten dass wir schon auch
gucken müssen dass wir nicht diesen
ideologischen kampf gegen das auto
führen das ist ja richtig glaube das ist
so das war es ein bisschen aus dem
herzen kommt gerade als jemand aus dem
ländlichen raum sage ich das auch klar
wir müssen da verschiedene
lebensrealitäten auch auffassen aber ich
glaube jetzt jedenfalls durch das thema
steuern gesellschaftspolitische probleme
zu lösen dann bin ich immer als
wirtschaftsliberaler politiker es finde
sich daraus winden sich auf
ordnungspolitik ab und ist doch aber
richtig ich will es nicht
möglich
eine der
größten gruppen im lande nämlich die
autofahrer in jeder hinsicht sein soll
man es von jedem liter benzin der bis
160 prozent nichts mit autofahren mit
das ist im moment ein problem
hängt ja ich bin ich bin senkung der
standards stolz gewesen war wirklich
passionierte auto war unfahrbar habe ich
jetzt heute ich bin heute diese fahrer
tritt die straßen entlang gefahren
wunderbare darüber dass daraus wollen
brauchen sie ja das braucht die straße
die sie brauchen wir leute die sagen wir
sind schon immer stellen hessing ich
finde haben dort mit einer sache völlig
recht ist ist auch heute schon so dass
das hier haftpflichtversichert sein
müssen oder eine eine vielzahl
privater sie stehen in der pflicht haben
dann müssen halt eine pflicht für wenn
man
durchs aber
die akkus nicht
mal mehr fahrrad also wissen sie was so
wissen sie wieder und wissen sie was
dann gibt es einen teil der bevölkerung
der aufzeigt und schaut ihn an der alten
teil der welt der nur laufen darf er
nichts geld hat für die verbände
seien zusagen über steuern löse ich das
jetzt mal also ist so typisch grüne
starts regulieren
diese sei in diesem kontext wirklich
beneide ich die schweiz oder dänemark
die haben diese völlig übertriebene
corona history erkannt haben die
maßnahmen komplett abgestellt
bereich quote für ein leben
bin ich jetzt ich würde das nicht so der
tech-werte ohne nicht wäre schon ein
wenn ich wäre schon sehr gut ich wäre
schon längst fertig wenn ich dürfte
genau und tun jetzt nachbereiten
überprüfen was war sinnvoll was er
übertrieben was ihr nicht gemacht wird
und können sich jetzt solchen themen
widmen ja das ist doch wunderbar wenn
wir die gesellschaft werden wo man über
solche die mir sprechen themen reden
sein neuer staatsverdrossenheit ja das
hätte ich ihnen was erzählen aber den
gegner gar nicht wenn der mensch aber
wir sind wir wissen dass wir uns nicht
mehr als terroristen beschimpft
darum sage ich es warum das man nicht
mehr leute also zahlen nennen weil sie
einfach angst vor einem neuen medikament
haben sondern dass wir über fahrräder
diskutieren sowas würde ich mir wieder
zurückwünschen